[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
[موسيقى]
في رساله سريه بايدن يهدد نتنياهو
بالاستبعاد من قمه الديمقراطيه اذا لم
يوقف التعديلات القضائيه
التزوير وخرق قوانين الانتخابات اتهامات
قد تضاف الى لائحه اتهام ترامب الجنائيه
المرتقبه
الرئيس الاماراتي يعين منصور بن زايد
نائبا للرئيس الى جانب محمد بن راشد وخالد
بن محمد بن زايد وليا للعهد في ابوظبي
ازمه البنوك الامريكيه تنعش العملات
المشفره وبتكوين تقود ركب الارتفاع وتقترب
من 30 الفا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه افادت وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه بان الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن وجه رساله قاسيه لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بعد اقالته وزير الدفاع
واوضحت المصادر الاسرائيليه ان بايدن طالب
نتنياهو بالتراجع فورا عن تعديلات القضاء
في رساله نقلها السفير الامريكي التي كانت
شخصيه وسريه وهدد الرئيس الامريكي رئيس
وزراء اسرائيل بالاستبعاد من قمه
الديمقراطيه اذا لم يوقف تعديلات القضاء
في السياق اكد مسؤول اسرائيلي ان نتنياهو
يريد تجنب ازمه مع بايدن ويريد وضع ازمه
القضاء خلفه
وازمه التعديلات القضائيه تخرج الى العلن
تخرج خلافات بين الحليفين القويين من
واشنطن الى تل ابيب والعكس ايضا يرفض
الرئيس الامريكي دعوه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي الى البيت الابيض في المستقبل
القريب فبايدن القلق للغايه يرى ان
الاستمرار في هذا الطريق ليس ممكنا
نتنياهو لا يتاخر يرد بشكل غير مسبوق رد
حمل اشارات واضحه الى الولايات المتحده
اسرائيل لا تخضع لضغوط من الخارج بما في
ذلك من افضل الاصدقاء وللاصدقاء تحديدا
يقول وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اثمار
بنجفير ان اسرائيل ليست نجمه على العالم
الامريكي متوقعا ان يفهم بايدن هذه النقطه
والسؤال الذي قد يطرح الان هل فهمت واشنطن
رساله تل ابيب القناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكي قوله
ان نتنياهو اخطا فهم الرد الامريكي على
انقلابه القانوني المسؤول الامريكي قال
ايضا ان نتنياهو اساء التقدير بتصريحاته
حول بايدن خرجت التصريحات اذن اصداؤها
سمعت في اسرائيل وفي واشنطن لكنه صدن يعكس
غضبا واحباطا امريكيا مه نتنياهو وحكومته
كما تقول صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت نقلا عن
مسؤول اسرائيلي كبير
خلافات بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده من
حين لاخر لكن اريد ان اؤكد لكم ان التحالف
بين اعظم ديمقراطيه في العالم واسرائيل
الديمقراطيه قويه والفخوره المستقله هذا
التحالف لا يتزعزع ولا يمكن لشيء ان يغير
ذلك
ورغم تحضيراتنا التناول اعضاء اعتلافه من
الحديث عن الازمه مع واشنطن الا ان وزير
التعليم الاسرائيلي
حذر الولايات المتحده من التدخل في شؤون
الداخليه الاسرائيليه وزير التعليم
الاسرائيلي اضاف ان نجله رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو غير متورط في اي شيء
يتعلق بخطه تغيير النظام القضائي
وفي رد على سؤال للعربيه قال المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
تصريحات رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
كان بها نقاط ايجابيه مشددا على ان بايدن
ونتنياهو يتمتعان بصداقه قويه تمتد
لاربعين عاما
اذا نظرنا الى تصريح نتنياهو هناك الكثير
من الايجابيه فيه تحدث عن البحث عن حل
الوسط وعن العمل على بناء توافق فيما
يتعلق بهذه الاصلاحات القضائيه المحتمله
وتحدث ايضا عن مدى ثباته في اهميه العلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل وعن
احترامه الكبير للرئيس بايدن وهذا احترام
يشاركه فيه الرئيس بايدن ايضا نتنياهو
وبايدن يعرفان بعضهما منذ اربعين عاما
والشيء الرائع في الاصدقاء وانا متاكد من
ان لدينا اصدقاء جميعا فنحن لا نوافق
دائما على كل ما يفعله او يقوله اصدقائنا
والشيء رائع في الصداقه العميقه هو اننا
يمكن ان نكون صريحين مع بعضنا
[موسيقى]
هكذا رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه ان
ايران اتخذت اجراءات لتحسين قدراتها على
انتاج سلاح النووي اشار ميلي الى ان
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بسياستها لمنع
طهران من امتلاك سلاح نووي
اتخذت ايران اجراءات لتحسين قدراتها على
انتاج سلاح النووي ومن وقت اتخاذ القرار
يمكن لايران انتاج ما يكفي من المواد
الانشطاريه لسلاح النووي خلال اقل من
اسبوعين والذي يستغرق الامر سوى عده اشهر
اخرى لانتاج سلاح نووي تظل الولايات
المتحده ملتزمه من حيث السياسه بعدم
امتلاك ايران سلاح النوويا الجيش الامريكي
طور خيارات متعدده لقيادتنا الوطنيه للنظر
فيما اذا كانت ايران ستقرر تطوير سلاح
نووي او متى ستقرر ذلك
[موسيقى]
الملف التالي في اخبار الساعه الحرف في
اوكرانيا رقعه المعارك في اوكرانيا تتغير
وتتسع بشكل مستمر لتشمل مناطق جديده اخر
هذه المناطق مدينه ميلوتوبولا التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا والتي تعرضت لقصف اوكراني
تسبب في انقطاع امدادات الكهرباء عن
المدينه وذلك نقلا عن وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه فما هي اهميه هذه المدينه ولماذا
تعرضت للقصف للاجابه عن هذا السؤال يجب
الاشاره الى ميلوتوبول تقع في منطقه حساسه
وهامه وذلك على بعد 120 كيلومترا جنوب
شرقي محطه ذا فروج نوويه
تعد مركز رئيسيا للسكك الحديديه بالنسبه
للجيش الروسي وهو ما يرجح ان يكون سبب
استهدافها هو قطع الامدادات عن الجيش
الروسي وجعلت روسيا ميليوتوبول عاصمه جزء
من منطقه التي قامت بالسيطره على اجزاء
واسعه منها
ومع استمرار الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وتزايد قسوه العقوبات الغربيه تعاني روسيا
من تداعيات اقتصاديه جسيمه في مؤشر على
انهيار اقتصاد الاقتصاد متوقع المتوقع على
المدى البعيد وفقا لتقرير لصحيفه
الاقتصاد الروسي يتكبد عواقب الحرب
الاوكرانيه
تقلص الميزانيه العامه الروسيه انخفاض
معدلات الاستثمار الاجنبي
الملياردير الروسي اوليج قال انه لن تكون
هناك اموال في العام المقبل هو ان روسيا
بحاجه الى مستثمرين اجانب
فيما قال صندوق النقد الدولي ان خساره راس
المال البشري والعزل عن الاسواق الماليه
العالميه اضافه الى اعاقه الوصول الى
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه ستؤدي الى اعاقه
الاقتصاد الروسي
[موسيقى]
تسود حاله ترقب بين الاوساط السياسيه
والامنيه في الولايات المتحده في ظل
التقارير التي تفيد بقرب توجيه لائحه
اتهام ضد الرئيس الجمهوريه السابق دونالد
ترامب بتهمن مرتبطه بدفع مبالغ ماليه
لممثله اباحيه هذا وقالت مصادر لشبكه سي
ان انينا مكتب المدعي العام في منهات لم
يتخذ اي اجراء حتى الان ضد ترامبا بيتها
من مرتبطه بدفع مبالغ ماليه للممثله
الاباحيه وكان موقع قد اشار الى ان توجيه
لائحه اتهام ضد ترامب امر غير مؤكد وفي
حال ما حدث فان التهم ستركز على تزوير
السجلات او خرق قوانين تمويل الانتخابات
او كليهما
هذا وقال محامي دونالد ترامب جو تاكوبينا
ان منشورات الرئيس الامريكي السابق ضد
مدعي عام منطقه منهاتن الذي يحقق معه في
اجراء نماليه محتمله غير حكيمه
ان دولار ترامب نفسه لم ينشرها
المزيد
انا لست مستشارا في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بهذه الجمله اخلى محامي الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب مسؤوليته عن
اي منشورات لترامب فهل تخلى اقرب موظفي
الرئيس الامريكي عنه
يعرف عن ترامب احبه وعشقه لمواقع التواصل
التي لطالما استخدمها لايصال رسائله
الخاصه لخصومه اخرها وجهت لشخص لم يكن
خصما ولا منافسا هو مدعي عاما هاتا الفن
براك المسؤول عن التحقيق في قضايا جنائيه
ماليه تلاحق ترامب اثناء حملته الانتخابيه
عام 2016 قبل ايام صعد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق من لهجته واشار في منشور الله عبر
منصته للتواصل
الى موت ودمار محتملين اذا تم توجيه
الاتهام اليه في القضيه
سبقتها جمله من ردات الفعل للرئيس
الامريكي السابق عبر سلسله تغريدات له
اثار بعضها حفيظه مناصريه ودفعت اخرين
للتحذير من تداعياتها تحدث فيها ترامب عن
مزاعم اعتقاله
هنا نعود للسؤال عن تفسير تصريحات ابرز
شخص حاليا في قضيه ترامب الجنائيه محاميه
والمدافع عنه جو تاكوبينا انتقد منشورات
الرئيس الامريكي السابق على الانترنت ضد
مدعي منطقه من هاتن ووصفها بغير الحكيمه
لكنه في الوقت نفسه لم يتخلى عن موكله
تماما بل اشار الى ان ترامب لم ينشر تلك
التهديدات بنفسه
اعتقد ان هذا كان منشورا غير حكيم وضعه
احد العاملين على وسائل التواصل وسرعان ما
حذفه عندما ادرك الخطاب والصوره المرفقه
به صرح ترامب ام لم يصرح ودين ام لم يدن
اذا كان هناك شيء واحد اصبح واضحا بشكل
متزايد بشان مستقبل ترامب الرئاسي لعام
2024 فهو ان هذه الحمله ستكون اكثر شراسه
من سابقتها
روان حمزه العربيه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه خلافات بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع تتصدر المشهد في
السودان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدر رئيس دوله الامارات
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيين الشيخ
منصور بن زايد نائبا لرئيس الدوله الى
جانب الشيخ محمد بن راشد وقرر الشيخ محمد
بن زايد تعيين الشيخ خالد بن محمد بن زايد
واليا للعهد في اماره ابوظبي كما اصدر
الشيخ محمد بن زايد قرارا بتعيين الشيخ
هزاع بن زايد والشيخ طحنون بن زايد نائبين
لحاكم ابو ظبي
[موسيقى]
الى السودان الخلافات الخفيه وبين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع تتصدر المشهد في
السودان وتبعث باشارات غير مطمئنه في جديد
هذا الخلاف غيابه ممثل القوات المسلحه في
ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري عن الجلسه
الختاميه للورشه غياب يعكس عمق الخلاف بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ونقلا عن مراسل
العربيه فان الخلافات بين الجانبين تتمحور
حول الاوراق المقدمه للاصلاح وكيفيه الدمج
وفتراته الزمنيه
وفي خضم هذا الخلاف اسدل الستار على
الورشه بتقديم توصيات حول عمليه الاصلاح
في الجهازين الامني والعسكري من ابرز ما
جاءت به التوصيات الدعوه الى ضروره تنفيذ
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري بالشراكه مع
المجتمع الدولي وتم الاقرار بصعوبه دمج
قوات الدعم السريع داخل الجيش رغم اهميه
الخطوه كما شدد البيان الختمي للورشه على
ان توصيتها اصبحت جزءا من الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي للبلاد
وشهدت الاسابيع الماضيه اندلاع خلاف بين
الجيش السوداني الذي يقود الحكم في البلاد
وقوات الدعم السريع فقاده الجيش يطالبون
بدمج قوات الدعم داخل صفوفه وهو ما تامل
قوات الدعم في تاجيله في الوقت الراهن
وتنامت في الاونه الاخيره مخاوفوا من
امكانيه ان يتطور هذا الخلاف بين الجانبين
الى اصطدام بينهما وهو ما استبعده رئيس
بعثه الامم المتحده لدعم الانتقال في
السودان بولكربرت والذي قال ان المواجهه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع غير مرجحه
نتابع من الخرطوم مع مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك بدايه الى اين وصلت
جهود حل الخلاف داخل المكون العسكري نتحدث
عن الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
نعم اهلا بكم بكل المشاهدين بدايه كان
اليوم ختام هذه الورشه التي تفاجا الجميع
بغياب قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
ورئيس مجلس السياده وكذلك نائبه محمد
حمدان من حضور هذه الجلسه المعنيه
بالاصلاح الامني والعسكري بكل تاكيد ايضا
تفاجا الجميع بغياب الاجهزه
المتعلقه بالاصلاح نفسها وهي الشرطه وجهاز
المخابرات العامه وكذلك الجيش كل هذه
الاجهزه لم يحضر منها احد كل الحضور كانوا
من الاجهزه الامنيه فقط بعض من قاده قوات
الدعم السريع فقط هم الذين حضروا اليه
ختام هذه الورشه هذا ما دفع انه بعد نهايه
هذه الورشه مباشره كان هنالك اجتماع بين
الاليه الثلاثيه وكذلك اجتماع الاليه
الثلاثيه مع القوى الموقعه الاتفاق
الايطالي للنقاش حول هذا الموضوع لكن يبقى
الخلاف قائما هناك من يتحدث عن اجتماع
سيكون في هذه اللحظات ربما بدا هذا
الاجتماع بين
القائد قوات الجيش محمد عبد الفتاح
البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان مع القوى
الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي للنقاش حول
موضوع التوصيات التي يفترض ان تكتب وتناقش
بحديث الناطق الرسمي باسم العمليه
السياسيه اليوم في القاعده الفنيه ستواصل
عملها لصياغه التوصيات لتضمينها في
الاتفاق النهائي الذي سيوقع في الاول من
الشهر المقبل طيب سالم في هذه الاثناء
يعني هناك هذا الاجتماع
اصل الخلاف او جوهر الخلاف هنا مساله دعم
قوه دمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش هي
النقطه الخلافيه يعني
هل من المنتظر ان تحل هذه النقطه في هذا
الاجتماع وهل هناك اسباب اخرى لهذا الخلاف
داخل المكون العسكري يا سالم
اصل هذا الخلاف اذا نظرنا الى الايام
الماضيه في التصريحات المتتاليه ما بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ان اصل الخلاف
في موضوع الدمج نفسه ولكل وجهه نظر وجهه
نظر الجيش ان يتم دمج هذه القوات باسرع
وقت ممكن هذا ما يتحدث عنه الجيش السوداني
في المقابل قوات الدعم السريع تتحدث انه
لا اشكال لها مع موضوع الدمج لكن الاشكال
في كيفيه الدمج ازمنه الدمج كذلك تتحدث
قوات الدعم السريعه لانه قبل ان يتم هذا
الدم يجب ان يتم اصلاح المؤسسه العسكريه
نفسها ان هذا الاصلاح يطال المؤسسه
العسكريه ومن ثم تكون مهياه بحسب وصفهم
لاستقبال قوات الدعم السريع ودمجها بشكل
كبير هذا عن المكون العسكري سالم ماذا
عن اي مواقف او تصريحات من تصاعد هذا
الخلاف بهذا الشكل في المكون العسكري
نتحدث عن قوى الحريه والتغيير بالتحديد
والحريه والتغيير لم تصدر بيانا حتى
اللحظه المجلس المركزي ولا القوى الموقعه
على الاتفاق الايطالي كل من التقينا بهم
تحدثوا على انهم سيحتمون هذا الموقف وان
هذا خلاف فقط في تفاصيل تتعلق بهذه الورشه
وسيتم حل هذا الخلاف هذا ما تحدثوا عنه لم
يتحدثوا عن تصعيد لم يتحدثوا على ان هذا
الامر سيدفع الى خلاف كبير وذكروا جميعهم
بانه يمكن احتواء هذا الخلاف وتداركه قبل
توقيع الاتفاق النهائي لان هذه الورشه
متعلقه بالاتفاق النهائي بكل تاكيد لان
توصياتها يجب ان ترفع مباشره في الاتفاق
النهائي وتوقع الا اذا رات القوى الموقع
الاتفاق الاطار ان يتم ارجاء هذا الامر
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اسرعه الصيني التايواني يعود الى الواجهه
من جديد والسبب زياره الرئيسه التايوانيه
الى الولايات المتحده زياره لم تتاخر بكين
في شجبها حيث هددت باتخاذ اجراءات مضاده
حازمه بشان الاجتماع المزمع بين الرئيسه
التايوانيه ورئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
خلال مرور التاي بالولايات المتحده وذهبت
بكين الى حد مطالبه واشنطن بمنع اي لقاء
بين الرئيسه التايوانيه والمسؤولين
الامريكيين وذلك على لسان
المتحدثه باسم مكتب شؤون تايوان بمجلس
الدوله الصيني على الطرف الاخر فان الرئيس
التايوانيه لم تلتفت الى تحضيرات البكين
حيث قالت قبل توجهها الى الولايات المتحده
ان بلادها لن تستسلم لاي ضغوط خارجيه
[موسيقى]
يحاول السوريون اعاده الحياه الى المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال المدمر في الشمال
السوري حيث عادت الاسواق الشعبيه للعمل
بالروم من الصعوبات التي يعيشها السوريون
ويعد ارتفاع الاسعار وانعدام القدره
الشرائيه لديهم ابرز الصعوبات التي
يواجهونها خصوصا في المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال
عادت اصوات البائعين الى ناحيه جنديرس
المنكوبه لتملا احياءها المدمره بضجيج
الاسواق الشعبيه التي اعتاد الاهالي على
زيارتها لشراء البضائع بسعر اقل من تلك
التي تعرض في المحال التجاريه خصوصا ان
اغلب اهالي المنطقه عانوا من كارثه
الزلزال المدمر الذي اثر سلبا على القدره
الشرائيه لديهم بعد زلزال وضع تعبان
قبل كان كويس ماشي الحال تيجي العالم
وتروح هلا ما في حدا يعني نصف طلعت بره
يعني انا جاي ادرس بدي ابسط بدي اشتغل بدي
استمر بالحياه الحياه الحياه
اسمها يصير ما راح توقف تستمر الحياه حياه
مستمره
يشكو الاهالي هنا من ارتفاع الاسعار مما
دفع اغلبهم للاكتفاء بشراء المواد
الغذائيه الاساسيه وتجاهل اصوات بائعي
باقي البضائع ويعزو الاهالي ذلك بسبب
الكارثه التي حلت بهم والاضرار التي لحقت
بممتلكاتهم ما في قدره شرائيه غير على
الخضره كمال عام عم تشتغل وتشتري خضره
تماما فقط لا غير بالنسبه للالبسه والباله
والجديد شغله ضعيف ما في ما في عندنا
الناس قدره ما في عندها قدره شرعيه يعني
عايشه اول باول اغراض غاليه وين بدي اجيب
وين اجيب في رحمه الله عنا يحاول السوريون
العوده للحياه رغم ضعف الامكانيات خصوصا
بعد كارثه الزلزال الذي تسبب بفقدان
الكثير من الاهالي لممتلكاتهم واعمالهم
مما ادى لتراجع الحركه الاقت صاديه في
عموم المنطقه احيت اصوات الباعه وضجيج
المتسوقين الامل في المناطق التي ضربها
الزلزال في شمال غرب سوريا
ليشوبها ارتفاع الاسعار وعدم قدره الاهالي
على شراء كافه احتياجاتهم خصوصا ان اغلبهم
فقد منزله وعمله وبات يعيش في خيمه قماشيه
محمد الاشقر العربيه شمال سوريا
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الامير هاري
يهاجم العائله المالكه من جديد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد خصصت الرئاسه العامه
لشؤون المسجد الحرام 25 موظفا يعملون على
قياس رضا المعتمرين وكافه الخدمات المقدمه
لهم من خلال خمسه وسبعين لوحا تمكن
الزائرون من ابداء ارائهم حول الخدمات
المقدمه لهم في المسجد الحرام وذلك
للتحسين منها
[موسيقى]
توافد كبير وطاقه قصوى للمسجد الحرام في
استقبال مئات الالاف من المعتمرين والزوار
يوميا خلال شهر رمضان هذه الاعداد الكبيره
تتطلب تطويرا مستمرا للخدمات عبر قياسي
رضاهم عن الخدمات المقدمه تعمل اداره تج
ضيف الرحمن وفق معايير متبعه من مركز اداء
الوطني لقياس الجهات الحكوميه كذلك تعمل
الاداره على اربع ورديات مختلفه تقوم
بقياس نسبه الرضا وفق معايير معتمده من
مركز اداء الوطني لقياس الجهات الحكوميه
يقوم يقوم الفريق الميداني في النزول على
ارض الواقع واخذ الانطباعات مباشره ورفع
تقارير لحظيه مسوح احصائيه ميدانيه تجريها
وكاله قياس الاداء والجوده بالرئاسه
العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام بشكل يومي حيث
تستهدف استطلاع اراء خمسه الاف معتمر
ومصلي يقوم المختصين لدى المركز بعمليه
المقابله الشخصيه مع المعتمرين
وسؤالهم عن المده المستغرقه في كل قسم من
هذه الاقسام الخاصه بالعمره سواء في
الطواف او في السعي لمده الانتقال بين
الطواف والسعيد وبعد ذلك يقوم مركز الحصان
والمعلومات باخذ متوسط مده المتوسط مده
العمره جاهزيته المصليات واعمال النظافه
واداره الحشود ابرز الخدمات التي يجري بحط
رضا المعتمرين عنها لتفادي اي اخطاء فيما
تبقى من شهر رمضان
واستعدادا للموسم الاكبر موسم حج هذا
العام من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
نتابع من الحرم المكي الشريف مع مراسلنا
سلطان السلمي هو معنى من هناك على المباشر
سلطان اهلا بك معنا رئاسه الحرمين خصصت
160 بابا للمعتمرين من اجل الانسيابيه
اكثر في خروجهم ودخولهم الى الحرم ما الذي
رصدته عن انسيابيه حركه المعتمرين
اهلا بك صهيب اهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه وبشكل ميداني نشاهد الان هذه
الابواب التي تم والمسارات التي تم
تخصيصها من قبل رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين
وكذلك كافه القطاعات الامنيه العامله على
تنظيم واداره الحشود هنا داخل الحرم المكي
او حتى في الساحات الخارجيه الخاصه بالحرم
المكي وتحديدا في المنطقه المركزيه كما
نشاهد باب الملك عبد العزيز ووالد الدخول
وايضا فيما يتعلق بباب اجياد واسماعيل وهو
للخروج في هذه المنطقه وفي هذا المربع
الذي نتحدث الان منه نتحدث عن عرب توفير
14 مسار سبعه من اهل الدخول وسبعه اخرى
للخروج نتحدث على محطات
للحافلات وهي خمس محطات للحافلات تنتشر في
كافه الجهات الخاصه بالحرم المكي وتحديدا
في المنطقه الشماليه والجنوبيه والغربيه
والشرقيه هذه المحطات التي تقوم بانزال
المعتمرين القادمين من محطات النقل الى
الحرم المكي ومن ثم يبدا السير كما
تشاهدون الان في انسيابيه كبيره تعمل
عليها وتحديدا قوات الطوارئ الخاص هنا في
هذه المنطقه وكذلك وزاره الحج والعمره
وايضا رئاسه شؤون الحرمين يتم تفويج
المعتمرين وفق خطط زمنيه تم العمل عليها
وحجزها في وقت سابق من قبل شركات العمره
بالتنسيق مع رئا الحرمين وحتى وزاره الحج
نعم طيب سلطان شهر رمضان من الفترات التي
يرغب فيها المسلمون في التوجه الى البقاع
المقدسه من اجل ان يعيشوا يعني ان يعتمروا
طبعا وان يعيشوا الاجواء الرمضانيه هناك
في
الحرمين الشريفين ما المختلف في هذا
الموسم مع هذه الاعداد الكبيره مع العوده
الى استقبال اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين بعد
كورونا
اختلافات كبيره شهداء الحرم المكي وحتى
بشكل عام العاصمه المقدسه مكه المكرمه
تتحدث عن الاعداد الكبيره التي يستقبل
الحرم المكي يوميا اكثر من مليون ونصف
المليون بين معتمر ومصلين نتحدث عن فتح
الحجوزات من قبل وزاره الحج السعوديه تحدث
عن تطبيق نسك او حتى تطبيق توكلنا يستطيع
من خلاله المواطن او حتى المقيم وايضا
القادم من الخارج الحجز عبر هذه المواقع
الثلاثه ومن ثم اخذ الموعد والوصول نتحدث
على فتح حجوزات كبير اين تحدث انه حتى في
العشر الاواخر الان القادمه متاح
للمعتمرين الحج واداء مناسك العمره تتحدث
عن المنطقه المركزيه المقابله الحرم المكي
اذ شهدت نسبه الاشغال في الفنادق في
الاسبوع الاول من شهر رمضان
95% من المتوقع انه في منتصف الشهر سوف
تصل الى مئه في المئه نتحدث على حركه
تجاريه كبيره حركه اقتصاديه كبيره نتحدث
على اكثر من 12 الف موظف يعملون من قبل
رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين لتقديم خدماتهم
للمعتمرين كذلك مضاعفه الجهود والخدمات
العامه التي تقام بها او يقام بها في داخل
الحرم المكي تم بشكل كبير تم ازدياد او
زياده اعداد العاملين بشكل ملحوظ في كافه
القطاعات نتحدث القطاعات الخدميه او حتى
القطاعات الامنيه كذلك الملفت هذا العام
زياده نسبه او تسخير الذكاء الاصطناعي
والتقنيات والريبورتات للعمل في الحرم
المكي بشكل كبير حتى تقوم بخدمه المعتمرين
نتحدث على سبيل يتحدث بلغات متعدده يقدم
خدماته في الافتاء شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
الصوره الحيه مباشره من الحرم المكي
الشريف سلطان السلمي مراسل العربيه
[موسيقى]
كن ساره للمتداولين في العملات المشفره
سوق العملات المشفره ينتعش من جديد رغم
المخاوف التي اعقبت انهيار بنك سيليكون
فالي الارتفاع الابرز اكبر عمله مشفره من
حيث القيمه السوقيه وذلك وسط مكاسب جماعيه
لسوق التشفير بشكل عام فبيتكوين صعدت
بنسبه 5.6 بالمئه في اخر 24 ساعه لتصل الى
ازيد من 28 الف دولار تقريبا كما ارتفعت
عمله الايثيريوم بنسبه تقاربه اثنين في
المئه متجاوزه قيمه 1800 دولار
[موسيقى]
الامير هاري لا يفوت فرصه دون مهاجمه
العائله الحاكمه في بريطانيا اخر
الانتقادات المواجهه من الامير المثير
للجدل اتهام العائله الملكيه بحجب معلومات
عنه في شان عمليه تسلط على هاتفه اجرتها
صحف بريطانيه الامير هاري ادلى بهذه
الاتهامات اثناء افادته باقواله خلال
جلسات الدعوه التي رفعها الى جانب مشاهير
اخرين
وبهذا نصل الى ختام اخبار الساعه لهذه
الليله تذكير بابرز العناوين
في رساله سريه بايدن يهدد نتنياهو
بالاستبعاد من قمه الديمقراطيه اذا لم
يوقف التعديلات القضائيه
التزوير وخرق قوانين الانتخابات اتهامات
قد تضاف الى لائحه اتهام ترامب الجنائيه
المرتقبه
الرئيس الاماراتي يعين منصور بن زايد
نائبا للرئيس الجانب محمد بن راشد وخالد
بن محمد بن زايد وليا للعهد في ابو ظبي
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]